Andrew you co-wrote the book The Human
planet Earth at the dawn of the
anthropocene which is the new age when
humans are actually having an impact on
the environment let me ask the question
of what do you find most beautiful and
fascinating about our planet Earth
it'd be cheap to say everything but just
walking here this morning under the
bridge over the Colorado River seeing
the birds knowing there's bat colonies
massive baton colonies around here that
I got to visit a few years ago I
experienced one of those bat explosions
it's fine mind-blowing uh the the I've
been really lucky as a journalist to
have gone to the North Pole just to camp
on the sea ice with Russian help at this
camp that was set up for tourists coming
from Europe every year there were
scientists on the sea ice floating on
the 14 000 foot deep Arctic Ocean and I
was with them for several days I wrote a
book about that too along with my
reporting
been in the depths of the Amazon
rainforest I've been when I was a very
young
I was the crew on a sailboat that sailed
two-thirds of the way around the world I
I was halfway across the Indian Ocean
again in 14 000 foot deep water we were
just there was no wind
and we were this is before way before I
was a journalist 22 23 years old
and we went swimming and swimming in 14
000 foot deep water
uh you know 500 miles from Land the
Western Indian Ocean halfway between
Somalia and the Maldives
is it like so mind-boggling chillingly
Fantastical thing with a mask on looking
at your Shadow going to the vanishing
point below you looking over at the boat
which is a 60-foot boat but just looks
like a toy and then getting back on and
being beholden to the elements the
sailboat you know heading toward um
Djibouti men's City in the power oh my
God and then you know and then um the
human
qualities are unbelievable you know the
anthropocene
I played a bit of a role as a journalist
and waking people up the idea that this
this era called the Holocene the last 11
000 years
you know since the last ice age had
ended I wrote my 1992 book on global
warming
thinking about all that we're just
talking about thinking about the wonders
of the planet thinking about the impact
of humans so far in our explosive growth
in the 20th century I wrote that perhaps
earth scientists of the future
we'll name this post Holocene
era for uh for its formative element for
us
because we're kind of
in charge in certain ways you know which
is hubristic at the same time it's like
you know the variability of the climate
system is still profound without with or
without global warming so this immense
powerful beautiful organism that is
Earth the all the different suborganisms
that are on it do you see humans as a
kind of parasite on this Earth no no do
you see it as a
um as something that helps the
flourishing of the entire organism that
can can
intelligence yeah hasn't yet
I mean is our is aren't we on uh the
ability of the collective intelligence
of the human species to develop all
these kinds of Technologies and to be
able to uh have Twitter to introspect
onto itself
I think you know I think we're doing uh
we're it's all the way we are it's
ketchup we're always in catch-up mode
you know
um right uh I was at the Vatican for a
big meeting in 2014 on sustainable
Humanity sustainable nature our
responsibility and it was a week of um
presentations by like Martin Reese who's
this famed British scientist a physicist
who has been on his podcast yeah great
yeah well he's you know he's fixated on
existential risk right yes he is so
there's a week of this stuff and um
the meeting was was kicked off by um
I wrote about it in the Cardinal
maradiaga who's I think from El Salvador
he's one of the Pope's kind of Posse he
gave one of the initial speeches and he
said nowadays
mankind looks like a technical Giant and
an ethical child
meaning our technological Wizardry is
unbelievable but it's way out in front
of our ability to step back and kind of
like
consider in the full Dimensions we need
to is it helping everybody is it uh what
what are the consequences of crispr uh
you know genetics technology and there's
no single answer to that if if I'm in
the African Union
I'm just using this as an example
crispr's emerged so fast it can do so
much by changing the nature of nature
in in a kind of a programming way not
you know building genes not just
transferring them from one organism to
another
We've Only Just Begun to taste the
fruits of that literally
um
and it can wipe out a mosquito species
we know how to do that now you can like
literally
take out the Dengue causing mosquito the
scientists have done the work
and you think okay cool well that's
great now there's this big fight over
whether that should happen
uh African Union and I'm with their View
says hey if we can take out a mosquito
species that's causing horrific chronic
loss through Dengue which I had once in
Indonesia it's not fun and um we should
do it you know and you're on the other
side of the European Union uh they're
they're saying using their
capital P precautionary
principle
says no we can't meddle with nature
right and this is just like we were
talking with climate you know there's
the real time question and the long-term
question and and there's the uh
people who are just facing the need to
get through the day and be healthy and
survive and have enough food
which is not integrated sufficiently at
all into the climate
stop climate change debate and those who
like are trying to cut CO2 which will
have a benefit
you know in the future by limiting the
fat tail
outcomes of this uh Journey we're on so
so when I think about the anthropocene I
think about this planet
I love that we're here right now I love
that our species has these capacities
I would love for there to be a little
bit more reflection
and where things come from and where
they might go whether you're a student a
kid
uh what's your role the wonderful thing
about the complexity of it is everyone
can play a role if you're an artist
or a designer or architect or an
economist or a podcaster
whatever you do just tweak a little bit
toward um
examining these questions stepping back
from the simplistic label throwing
toward what actually is the problem in
front of me whether it's in Pakistan or
or in
Austin or wherever you know Florida you
know what do you find beautiful about
this collective intelligence machine we
have from an economics perspective it's
kind of fascinating they were able to
there's there is a machine to it that
we've built up that's able to represent
interests and desires and value and
hopes and dreams in sort of monetary
ways
that we can trade with each other we can
make agreements with each other we can
represent our goals and build companies
that actually help and so on do you just
step back every once in a while and
Marvel at the fact that a few billion of
us are able to somehow not
create complete chaos and actually
collaborate and and have a collaborative
disagreements that ultimately or so far
have left led to progress yeah I think I
think fundamentally the point uh apart
from the fact that you know we should
just be joyful of the fact that uh
humans live here uh I think it's
incredibly important to remember how
much progress we've had uh you know most
people just don't stop to think about
those stats yeah I get that in the
normal bustle of day but just you know
in 1900 the average person on the planet
lived to be 32 years
32 years that was our average life
expectancy today it's about 74. uh so
we've literally got two lifetimes on
this planet each one of us and and you
know every year you live in in the rich
world you get to live three months
longer and the poor world is about four
months longer because of medical
advances because we get better at
dealing both with cancer and especially
uh right now with uh with heart disease
uh these are amazing achievements of
course it's a very very small part of it
we're much better fed we're much better
educated we've gone from a world where
virtually everyone or you know what 90
percent were were illiterate to a world
where more than 90 illiterate this is an
astounding opportunity and and 200 years
ago
95 94 percent
of the world were extremely poor that is
less than a dollar a day today that uh
for for the first time in 2015 it was
down below 10 so there and and again
these are kind of boring statistics but
they're also astounding uh Testaments of
how how well Humanity has done so just
on on the point of uh we've kind of just
been focused on making our own world
better uh and in many ways you know so
we've hunted a lot of big animals either
to Extinction or uh down to much much
smaller populations there's much smaller
populations of fish in the ocean so
there's a lot of of things that that
sort of fare the brunt of our success
not it's not because we're evil in that
sense it's just because we didn't All
Care all that much about them uh I think
it is important as one funnel of that
I'm not gonna make a big deal out of it
uh but the fact that we're putting out
more CO2 in the atmosphere uh because
CO2 as you also mentioned before it's
actually plant food uh you know if if
you're if you're a greenhouse grower you
know if you put in CO2 in your
Greenhouse you actually get bigger and
plumper tomatoes and and that's
essentially what we're doing in the
world this has overall bad consequences
and and that's why we should be doing
something about it but one of the good
side effects is actually that the world
is getting greener uh so we get much
more green stuff now I don't know and
and this is where I sort of show my
Economist uh Roots uh because if you
just measure all living stuff in uh in
tons uh so in weight there's actually
more living stuff than there were a
hundred years ago because elephants and
uh all these other you know Big Fish and
stuff are actually really really small
fraction of the world
yeah the fact that we have yes so we
have an enormous amount of live stuff
but that doesn't even measure it it's
mostly just wood yeah wooden green stuff
that yeah that's dramatically increased
in the world now we're still not not
there from what it was in 1500 so we've
we've still cut down the world a lot but
we're actually making a much Greener
World again not because we really cared
or thought about it but just sort of a
side effect of what we're doing I think
the crucial bit to remember is
when you're poor and you worry about
what's going to happen the next day
this is just not your main issue yeah am
I killing too many large animals in the
world but when you're rich and and you
can actually sit in a podcast in a
convenient place in Austin you can also
start thinking about this so one of the
crucial bits I think if we want to get
the rest of the world to care about the
environment care about climate care
about all these other issues we really
need to get them out of poverty first uh
and it's a simple point that we often
forget and get them connected to all
these gifts yes um I I have these
memories of
well I was reporting on the next big
earthquake that's going to devastate
Istanbul in 2009
I was in a slum
immigrant poor neighborhood
and walking around with an engineer
pointing out to the buildings that were
going to fall down this is all known
there was an earthquake in 1999 and the
next one's coming
one of my advantages in covering climate
is I've covered other kinds of disasters
too so it keeps my contexts you know
made in touch with other things we can
do so I'm walking around and
interviewing everybody went to the
school that's being retrofit they
actually were getting ahead of it there
the world bank provided some funding to
put in iron bars in the brick building
and and I I met these kids
um and they came when you're a
journalist with a camera and stuff in a
pad you get swarmed by kids uh mostly in
developing countries and so these kids
are running up to me and they weren't
going like are you American or just they
were saying Facebook Facebook
and I went that's interesting and I they
led me to their little town a little
Community Center that had a bank of
eight or ten pretty
flimsy computers and they're all there
playing a farm it was a game that was
hot at that time on Facebook Farmville
Farmville yeah and and you know my son
back in the Hudson Valley I remember him
playing it and and I thought wow that is
so freaking cool that these kids and
actually I became Facebook friends with
a couple of them afterwards we traded
our and I thought back to my youth when
we had pen pals I would write a letter
to a kid in West Cameroon
and he would write back and it took
weeks and it was a crinkly letter and I
never met him
and now you can kind of connect with
people and and that all through my
blogging you know at the New York Times
I was doing my regular reporting but I
launched a Blog in 2007 called dot Earth
which was all about what you were just
describing the newest fear the connected
world that's a term from these two
earliest 20 a Russian guy in early
fernatsuki and French Theologian and
scientist which is so interesting
tayard de charda they had this idea in
the early 20th century that we're
creating a planet of the Mind
that that human intelligence
can Foster
a better Earth and I just became smitten
with that especially meeting kids in
Istanbul slums who are on Facebook
looking with connectedness what can you
do with these tools which is what drives
me you know with my work now and
um but then there are these
counterweight counter currents that if
the connectedness can cut back you know
it allowed Al-Qaeda to recruit use
decapitation videos to recruit
distributed
disaffected young people into extremism
and you know there's lots of these
systems are not they're just like every
other tool right they're just for good
or ill and and the efficiency thing the
econ the economics
of the world which I also wrote about a
little bit
you know late 20th century it was so
cool that everything became so efficient
that our supply chains are just in time
manufacturing you know
getting the the stuff from where the
sources of the material are to the car
factory and to get the car to the floor
just in time for someone to buy it and
that and everyone got totally sucked in
by that including me it's great you know
super efficient cheaper and then kovid
hit and the whole supply chain
concept crumbled and one of the big
lessons there hopefully and this is
relevant to sustainability generally
is efficiency matters but but resilience
matters too and resilience is
inefficient you need redundancy
or
or a variety of options right which is
not what companies think about which is
not what if you're only focused on a
bottom line short-term timeline
those disruptions are not what you're
thinking about you're still thinking
about can we get that widget here just
in time for this thing to happen and
then on we go
so it's kind of I love the nosphere this
newest fear
idea the connectedness is fantastic oh
wait another thing like in the early 90s
when I wrote my first book on global
warming
it was for an exhibition at the Museum
of Natural History
um the environmental defense fund was
involved they were like a partner
one of these long-standing environmental
groups and they're very old-fashioned
it's mostly lawyers really just using
the Clean Air Act Clean Water Act to
litigate against pollution
and now EDF is vastly bigger
and they're actually this coming year
they're launching a satellite a an
environmental group
is launching methane sat and it's
providing a view an independent view of
where there's this gas
you know same thing natural gas is
basically methane so if you have a leak
whether it's in Siberia or in Oklahoma
you can cross-reference you can ground
true you can identify the hot spot you
can
know where the problem is to fix in so
many ways and that's just one example
I'm like if somebody told me in 1993
that EDF was going to launch it for
methane satellite it would have left out
loud so technology plays a huge role
if it's kind of you know employed with
these the bigger vision and Leadership